well if i'm honest i'm still in shock i
just can't believe
that uh something like this is gonna go
ahead um
you know because when you take all the
when you take the top six out of the
premier league
it just takes all the the passion out of
it because
you know when you look back at the
premier league it's been brilliant for a
long time
um and it doesn't really need changing
you know you get fantastic moments
especially like when
leicester won the premier league a few
years ago you know you say to me now
that
that's never going to happen again
because leicester won't be playing
indeed
playing against any of the top six it's
just it's just something that i don't
like i don't like the sound of it i
really don't want it to happen
i mean the the esl if it goes ahead it's
going to be like mid-week
as far as we understand it now there's
no guarantee that these people the the
big six will be taken out of the premier
league but
are you saying that would be a necessary
move that should happen as
at least some some form of punishment
well i think something's got to be done
because i think what will happen is that
the premier the teams that are in the
esl
will prioritize that and then start
putting out understand teams to play in
the premier
league you know because they'll think
that that's a more important um
competition and that's the other thing
about the
esl is that the only competition in that
league
is actually to winning you know what
happens if you lose your first few games
and you've got no chance of winning that
league what are you going to be playing
and playing exhibition games for the
rest of that season
it's just something that it doesn't sit
right with me and
you know like i said i just hope it
doesn't happen is it all about the money
it certainly looks like that i can't see
any other
advantage of it um you know it is all
about the money it's
it's owners obviously these owners are
very very
accomplished businessman they see an
offer that they think is great
not just for them but for their clubs as
well but
is it right for the fans for me it's not
you know you take you know where you
you look you listen to every interview
you go on the radio all the fans
don't want it you know and a lot of the
players even speaking last night james
milner said that he doesn't like the
idea and he doesn't want it to happen
you know that's a liverpool chapter
telling you this
you know even jurgen klopp said it you
know something just said
these are big guys in football you've
got to listen to these sort of people
but are they going to listen to them i
mean that's the you know if this this is
being driven by the owners
and you know managers well they can
leave if they don't like it i guess
the players could ultimately leave if
they don't like it i mean
their hands are pretty much tied in some
respects aren't they
they're very much tied um you know and
even last night you know there's reports
of
you know leeds fans having to go up the
liverpool team bus and
you know i can't you don't want that to
happen because the players haven't got
to really be saying this you know
they've got to go
with what the owners say i'm sure the
managers have got a good say
you know they can have talks with the
owners and tell them
you know what it's like at ground level
um you know because it's it's not going
down very well at all but
um you know i said these guys are very
good business guys
um i'm sure they're just dipping the toe
in the water to see
what sort of reaction they got and i
think it's a hundred times worse than
what they ever thought of
yeah i mean there are there are people
saying this would destroy the game
in in england at least i mean did would
you go along with that is it as strong
as that
it's certainly not going to help it um
you know and especially after a pandemic
a lot of the clubs in the lower division
are really struggling and i think that
once the top six go away
obviously sponsorship deals will be
lessened um
and you know so that filters all the way
down the pyramid um if you if you take
the topics away the money goes with that
you know they are in a very strong
position there's no doubt about that
but you've got to look after you know
why are we totally disrespected at over
100 years at the football league
and 100 years of fans just absolutely
love it you know the fans don't like
this
and i'm sure that there's they've got a
lot more to say in this as well
so when joel glaser said on sort of
late sunday night you know the the this
will help the the financial football
pyramid and when
florentino florentino perez said
yesterday
you know this is about saving the game
you don't believe them i don't i don't
believe it's going to be saved in the
game
um if it is then we need we need more
more clarity we need to know what sort
of
or how it's going to save the game you
know because all that i can see and all
that fans can see at the moment
is just that the top the top clubs of
their owners
earning even more money um and it
doesn't look like it's going to be put
down into the pyramid